[Music]
a new month brings a new batch of
content to stream on netflix from a
netflix original movie that will make
you swoon to new series to binge
here are the best movies and tv shows to
watch on netflix
in february 2021 perhaps the biggest
netflix original movie of february 2021
is a long-awaited third and final
installment in the to all the boys
cinematic franchise to all the boys
always and forever
based on author jenny han's novel always
and forever
lara jean the film picks up after the
events of to all the boys p.s
i still love you which saw lara jean
covey enjoying a rough patch with her
fake boyfriend
turned real boyfriend peter kabinsky
into all the boys always and forever
lara jean embarks on two trips that will
completely change her life and cause her
to reevaluate what her future will look
like
after she graduates high school will
peter and lara jean stick together in
the end
or will lara jean decide she wants to
spread her wings and be a single
independent butterfly as she heads off
to college you'll have to wait until the
movie hits netflix on february 12th
to find out before then though there are
a number of fantastic netflix original
flicks to get excited about
on february 3rd black beach about a
lawyer facing his dark past
after he reunites with an old friend and
all my friends are dead
about a group of friends memorable new
year's eve party drop on netflix
february 5th brings the black and white
drama malcolm and marie which centers on
the title characters unraveling the
darker parts of their relationship
during the night of malcolm's movie
premiere
though netflix is getting into the
lovey-dovey spirit in february 2021
that doesn't mean that all its film
offerings for the month skew toward the
romantic
some do but others hit all sorts of
other emotions sure to satisfy the
various types of cinephiles out there
all month long
you mustn't be afraid to dream a little
bigger darling
looking to revisit a mind-bending
christopher nolan film stream inception
on netflix beginning on february 1st
want to distract yourself from the candy
hearts and cutesy card filled holiday of
february and remember the cheery days of
december
or while laughing at chevy chase's wild
antics national lampoon's christmas
vacation
is the movie for you and it's arriving
on netflix on the first of the month
action movie fans will want to set aside
some time to watch jason statham in the
bank job
about the baker street robbery that took
place in london in 1971
on february 1st and war dogs starring
miles teller and jonah hill as two arms
dealers
carrying out a massive ammo supply deal
on february 8th
the first of the month brings martin
scorsese's draw-dropping psychological
thriller shutter island while later on
february 21st
both the conjuring and the conjuring 2
arrive to the streamer's digital shelves
near the end of the month on february
26th cue up two movies that are
returning to netflix after some time
away
and one that's new to the platform
captain fantastic a comedy drama about a
family emerging from a decade long
isolation
and rejoining society no escape the
action thriller starring going wilson as
a family man stuck in a foreign country
amid an uprising and our idiot brother
featuring paul rudder's a titular
character
who gives his three sisters all sorts of
grief
netflix original series to keep your
eyes on throughout february 2021
include firefly lane a drama following
two best friends who experience
trials and tribulations throughout their
30 years of companionship
the crew a comedy set in a nascar garage
where a seasoned crew chief clashes with
his team of millennial staff
and ginny and georgia which follows the
title characters
as their small family settles down in
new england additionally you'll want to
make some space in your netflix queue
for nadia bakes
a cookery series featuring nadia hussein
of the great british bake off fame
which will hit the streamer on february
12th
early on in the month the platform is
scooping up the third installment of the
anthology series the sinner
this one centered on a man named jamie
burns viewers can stream it beginning on
february 6th
if more family-friendly fair is what
you're after this february
the first two seasons of nickelodeon's
icarly arriving on the eighth of the
month
should do the trick looking to balance
laughs with thrills next month check out
the third season of nbc's good girls
starring christina hendricks
retter and mae whitman as three mothers
who decide to take their fates and their
finances in their own hands by robbing a
supermarket
good girls season 3 will be available to
stream starting on february 16th
speaking of heart racing february 24th
marks the arrival of the second season
of two sentence horror stories
the anthology series comprised of 30
minute horror shots
the episodes will air on the cw
throughout january before hitting
netflix at the end of february
both the stand-up comedy and documentary
sections of netflix's library will grow
a bit bigger in february
starting with the arrival of season 2 of
the emmy-winning special tiffany haddish
presents
they ready and the netflix debut of
strip down rise up
in this collection of they ready haddish
introduces six of her favorite comedians
who will perform
short but hilarious sets strip down rise
up is a documentary that explores how
women who pole dance are reclaiming
their authority
autonomy and confidence through movement
and meaning
a few days later on february 10th the
true crime documentary crime scene the
vanishing at the cecil hotel
arrives on netflix the first in a series
of documentaries focused on crime scene
locations
the vanishing at seesaw hotel recounts
the events that took place
leading up to during and after the
disappearance and death of eliza lam
a canadian student whose body was found
in the cecil hotel's water tank
for a markedly more light-hearted
documentary experience
check out pele which tells the story of
how the ultra famous brazilian
footballer became the sports icon he's
remembered as today
pele hits netflix on february 23rd that
same day brian regan stand up special on
the rocks will be available to stream on
netflix and on the 12th of the month
hate by daddy roevir also joins the
netflix library
early in the month erased and lila and
eve will depart from netflix
followed by don't knock twice on
february 7th and the bad moms christmas
on february 10th
the following day the will ferrell mark
wahlberg buddy cop movie the other guys
will have its final day in the sun on
the streaming platform
on valentine's day both alone in berlin
and hostiles say goodbye to netflix
other notable films leaving netflix in
february include the hilarious and
charming emma stone comedy easy a
the classic score says he crime film
goodfellas the heart-wrenching romantic
drama a walk to remember
and clint eastwood's 2008 drama gran
torino
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite netflix originals are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you